fin de la emisión para larry king
el legendario periodista y presentador
de televisión falleció en el hospital
cedars sinaí en los ángeles tras ser
ingresado por kobe 19
de sus 87 años de vida dedico más de 7
décadas a la comunicación entrevistó a
miles de personas desde madonna hasta
vladimir putin y todos los presidentes
de eeuu desde gerald ford hasta barack
obama
siempre vistiendo sus característicos
tirantes y gafas las conversaciones de
kim con los protagonistas de la historia
contemporánea ya forman parte de la
biblioteca mundial del periodismo la
cultura y la política
trataba a todos los invitados por igual
no importaba si era un presidente o
alguien de la calle y nunca quiso estar
preparado para las entrevistas quizás
era esta falta de preparación la que
llenaba de frescura sus conversaciones
que huían de la confrontación y que lo
tuvieron frente a las cámaras y
micrófonos durante años
no puedo creerlo son siete décadas si
llego al 2020 serán ocho décadas
tengo 83 años pero no me siento de 83
y es que quin no dejó nunca de trabajar
hijo de brooklyn en nueva york' se mudó
a miami en su juventud para trabajar en
la radio hasta llegar a la cnn donde
desarrolló la mayor parte de su carrera
con sus famosos programas nocturnos
superó un ataque al corazón un cáncer de
próstata y un apoplejía
hasta que su salud cedió de manera
definitiva
pero el recuerdo de kinky de sus
entrevistas permanecerá así se hayan
apagado las cámaras